The strength of the film is it's diverse cast and complex ideas about democracy,
about our individual responsibilities, about the moral choices that we bear, and that our elected officials
must themselves negotiate.
Are they acting in their interests or our interests?
Whatever happens dude best of luck, you win, I support you fully.
My name is Steven Garza and I'm running for governor.
What happens when you bring together over a thousand teenage boys from Texas
and ask them to go through a mock election?
What can this experiment tell us about how the complex views of individuals get translated into politics?
Is the electoral process more about tribal competition or actual policy preferences?
Those are just some of the questions explored by the new film Boys State.
As to the political views voice of my speech sometimes you got to say what you got to say in an attempt to win.
I think he's a fantastic politician but i don't think a fantastic politician is a compliment either.
Boys state is a program of the American legion there's a program for girls too called Girl State,
and they're week-long annual civics camps held in the summer.
In 2017 we read that the boys in Texas had voted to secede from the union.
That provocative act got some attention it
got our attention
and we thought what an interesting
program because it actually brings
together
teenagers from all different political
backgrounds and they get together and
they talk to each other and they
they run for office they pass bills what
do you say it's like the running of the
bulls
it's like suddenly they're released into
the um
yard and as you see in the film they
start their signature gathering for who
the people who want to become governor
and sort of the alpha male
business starts happening very quickly
it's a little early to start running for
governor don't you think
we don't even have a party formed yet
you don't have any
support in the primaries no but if you
have to start early you have to
you don't have to start this early what
do you believe in uh
my views will most likely align with the
party for the majority of them
i want to hear open debates so in other
words you're waiting for the party to
come up with an opinion and then you're
gonna
go with the party what do you stand for
though
you stand for freedom it's a bold policy
the
culmination of the of the event is the
election of of governor and then the
lesser offices
the project is really to learn about the
challenges of the electoral
process and of representative democracy
not so much the challenges of then
governing
it's interesting to me that the process
of boys state
is set up in such a way to
put people in parties immediately
without knowing what their platform is
without knowing who their leader is and
then they figure out what the parties
mean later
and i'm wondering if you think that
helps or hurts
any sort of parallels we might see in
our current political environment
this is a question that we we've
wrestled with um i mean
does the party structure federalists
versus nationalists kind of
immediately introduce a sort of tribal
competition and you see this
literally like chess beating you know
beat the federalists beat the
nationalists
well they don't stand for anything yet
what are you actually beating but also
as a mirror reflection of what actually
happens in our country
there is two parties that rule the
school and i think to some degree the
question here is
can those two parties in their tribal
space in their tribal face-off have
civil discourse that's the whole idea
is you are on opposite sides of i mean
you know
i guess a sports analogy would be on the
opposite end of the field can you still
um talk to each other i will skip the
part where i brag for three minutes
about how great and cool i am seeing as
we are all
qualified young men of skill and
character
people like that stuff yeah people like
that stuff a lot
some people say they're a sports junkie
i say i'm a politics junkie
the heart of the conflict the more
glorious i'm playing this like a game
i would like very much to win i love it
boys i love it where you from i come
from a very modest family
i'm on the course to be the first one to
graduate from high school i'm
a progressive person and i'm in a room
full of mostly conservative people
our masculinity shall not be infringed
i've never seen so many white people
ever i feel like
everybody has a secret underlying need
for bipartisanship
a message of unity as good as it sounds
is not winning anyone any elections
i think you know regardless of where you
come from on the political spectrum i
think you're going to find an entry
point in this film and you're going to
find
um i think in an unlikely place i think
a valuable perspective on where we're at
as a country
a lot of questions that we leave to the
audience uh it's
i think a complicated story we have very
diverse complicated characters
i think in documentary we sometimes
hunger for a kind of certain binary
truth
and and we all know that's really not
reality uh we want simplistic heroes and
and maybe we should expect more uh
complicated ones
it was interesting to see not so much in
the party platforms but amongst
the boys collectively certain um issues
um positions that
sort of ran in in ways that we wouldn't
expect
i mean they were as a whole much more
tolerant it seemed of
social social issues than we imagined
texas teenage predominantly white
conservative boys to be so
they were not all predictable and i
think maybe they're just modern 17 year
old
boys did you walk away from this hopeful
i did did you oh very much so i mean i
love that it's honest and
it was shocking and frightening and i
saw some of the darker currents
of of our politics um in in
expressed by young men which is alarming
um
i i expect they would be expressed by
young women too i think
it's no surprise but i think that um
and i don't agree with all of their
politics all these guys in the movie but
i really did
all of them i was inspired by them
and i was i am hopeful you know and it's
nice to be hopeful in a dark moment